[Music]
it's a sort of
virtual autopsy we can do a sort of fly
through
inside the mummy so we can study the
mummy
we can reconstruct the life and the
death of this
person we can also be sure about the sex
because we can study the pelvis we can
measure him
so we can understand how high it was
and then we will do also some chemical
and physical analysis to understand
which kind of product will use to
mummify
the body and also we can do
the radiocarbon dating
[Music]
all the information we have about the
mummies come
from the coffin so on the coffin he's
written the name
five times we are not sure exactly if
this
mummy is really the priest
because in the past with the antiquity
market
was quite frequent to associate a mummy
to another coffee
[Music]
the mummies are practically a biological
museum
they are like a capsule of time
and this is something that we understood
egyptologists and researchers we
understood in the last 10 years
[Music]
so
[Music]
you